Good morning Hank it's Monday. First I have
to correct something about your video from
Friday: You said the Project For Awesome begins
at midnight on December 17th, in fact it begins
at Noon Eastern time December 17th. So upload
your videos as close to noon as possible and
then tune into youtube.com/p4a.
So Hank today I want to tell you about 8 things
I love.
Thing one: this book, 'Anna and the French
Kiss' by Stephanie Perkins. Holy Snood do
I love this book! So a couple years ago at
LeakyCon a Nerdfighter comes up to me and
she says: "I'm a Nerdfighter and I wrote a
book, it's coming out in 2010, can I send
you a copy?" and I said, "sure". Right so
flash forward 2 years, I get this book in
the mail and I'm like "I'll read a page or
two," and then I can't stop reading it because
it is made of sweetness and funny and awesome.
Hank, 'Anna and the French Kiss' is like Maureen
Johnson and I had a baby, a French baby. No,
it is nothing like that. But it is super-funny
and smart and one of the most genuinely romantic
stories I have ever read.
Second thing I love: Karen Kavett, who designed
that. Karen has been a Nerdighter forever,
she designed the Project for Awesome thumbnail
this year, she did all the French Revolution
videos, and I'm just so grateful for her.
Thing three: Beckoning Lovely. Hank, as you
know I'm obsessed with my friend Amy Krouse
Rosenthal's Beckoning of Lovely project, in
which she tries to beckon lovely things into
the world. You can find a link to what happened
on 10/10/10 in Chicago in the dooblydoo, and
it might make you cry. It makes me cry, uhh,
but I'm a crier. Hank I don't think you've
ever cried in any of our videos, I'd like
to see you cry in a video. I can't-I don't
think I've seen you cry since you were a kid.
Probably the last time I saw you cry was when
I was punching you.
Thing four: this shirt, which is currently
stuck on my glasses, and which was given to
me by Nerimon. Thanks Alex!
Thing five: Charlie. So Hank I met Charlie
McDonnell when he was, to use the language
of his native country, but a young lad. But
even back then I remember thinking, "This
kid, aside from being outrageously handsome,
is kind of a genius." Ever since, Charlie
has been proving me right, but never more
than on his new album 'This is Me', which
is honestly-I haven't been able to stop listening
to it on iTunes. It's the only thing in my
iTunes. I have 'Bread' on repeat, and I've
listened to it..621 times. This raises the
alarming possibility that I might technically
be a fangirl. Also, on the back of his CD
he wrote, "I hope you like it" and then "Hopeful
Charlie". I liked it, Charlie.
Thing six: white dog on white snow.
Thing seven: Hank, I have perhaps saved the
best for nearly last. So a couple weeks ago
my friend Joe Felice asked me to participate
in 'The Station is Watching You', a show that
works to give new YouTubers a bigger audience.
Joe chose for me a user named Vi Hart, and
French the Llama is she amazing! The crazy
part of the story is that Vi Hart has been
a Nerdfighter since 2007 and in fact designed
the original Nerdfighter pirate logo. Nerdfighters-
click here, watch a Vi Hart video, and your
whole life will be changed. You may think
you hate Math, but you don't hate Math, you
hate the way you've been taught Math. Hank
she can also play Jingle Bells with candy
buttons, which is a major development in the
history of candy buttons.
And lastly Hank, thing eight: the Napoleon.
So Hank this is Napoleon, and lately my son
Henry has taken to pointing in the direction
he would like to be taken. Hank, I love the
Napoleon because Henry clearly believes that
I am a horse. He's like: "And now we shall
head that way, horse. To the candy!"
So Hank that's stuff I love: Nerdfighters
writing books and making music and making
videos about mathemusicianship. Nerdfighters,
please tell me some stuff that you love so
I can find new stuff to love, and Hank - don't
forget to be awesome.